like i it's almost amazing to me that
i'm the guy that was with aliyah
do you think he would have married her
one day
yeah because you hear all this other
stuff in the news with r kelly how do
you how does that make you feel about
him
we talked about it up to the point where
it hurt
and then she said i don't want to talk
about it no more
first of all
this has to be a hard time this
anniversary coming up
of alia's passing
what goes through your mind
well
it's amazing that it's been so long
but it still feels like yesterday
like literally
you know i was reflecting today
there hasn't been one day since she's
passed not one in the 20 years that i
haven't either heard her name heard a
record or seen a picture of her every
single day she's present in my life and
i feel lucky for that
what did we lose by losing her
where would she be today it's where the
world would be today right the
trajectory of the world would have been
a lot different
had she been on this planet you know
because she was an opinion leader she
was one of those people that if she did
something first everyone followed suit
so yeah she was just building herself as
a brand
you know so again the trajectory of the
world would have been a lot different
because she was a very forward thinker
do you think you would have married her
one day
yeah
i mean you know the plan was
because we were both so busy so while
she was shooting um
the movie in australia i was shooting
paid in full so i couldn't fly to
australia to go see her she was going
for four months and when she came back
you know she had to be in la to rehearse
for a video while i had to do whatever i
was doing i had companies to run so we
would have such a good time when we saw
each other
you know it was like it just always felt
fresh so our thing was you know let's
see if we can like tolerate being around
each other with no distractions for six
months if we still have this same
feeling then we'll get married but our
intention at first wasn't even to be in
love we were just really good friends
and we fell for real it was almost an
accident but what i learned from that
number one
i didn't know what being in love was i
didn't even understand what that feeling
is
and i was able to really achieve that
with her so now i know what it feels
like so i was able to identify it when
it happened again you know and after she
passed it changed my whole life because
i would only do what i love i would only
be around people i love that became the
only currency i cared about is how i
felt but everyone here is either going
to lose someone they love or they're
going to be a lost to someone they love
we're doomed the day we're born so in
between that time we have to enjoy life
and marinate the things that really
count
but i never thought about what it would
feel like to lose my girl
you didn't want her to go did you
no
so
she was shooting a video in miami yep
and i had my son and my nephews
with me
and you know she was very supportive she
particularly liked freeway his voice and
she was supportive of anything i was
doing she was like while i'm in miami i
had the state property down there
which was a group yeah and she was gonna
do a record with freeway
so i was like all right i'm gonna come
down here i'll check you
i'll bring the kids make a vacation work
the whole night
so when we got there
you know hype was making this video and
i was like i know hype i just got off of
uh
big pimping where i had to cut the video
you know what i mean it was like spin
brett so i was like
you know he's going to make you do
another day don't do it trust me it's
just so he could spend money you know
and
sure enough she came home that day and i
had a big house i read this house and
she's like i'm going to you know there
and i was like
i just thought that it was uh
it wasn't necessary you know i knew that
that was gonna happen and then
when she actually was uh saw the plane
she
uh you know we had the blackberries and
she said i don't like this plane
and i was like well don't get on it and
she was like well i got to because
i got work to do
she got in the plane and she always had
a very serious fear of planes in general
so she had to overcome a fear to get on
that plane
on the way there
um but what i was really more tired
about was that i had heard that lenny
kravitz had offered her a jet and then
hype and took the jet so that's what
really pissed me off about the situation
when i heard about that so you could ask
hype about that
have you ever have you ever talked to
hype about it yeah and how did that
conversation go
ask her
but also i'm asking you yeah but ask him
i feel like you had some things to say
to him because of my respect for leah
and her family her music is like is just
coming out but everyone's very
respectful of her memory no one really
speaks on it because that's the circle
of people she had around so out of
respect for her memory
i don't say a lot of things
tell me about that day where were you
i was getting my hair cut
and i was waiting for her so
you know
she was trying to get back really
quickly because we were trying to see
each other so she was like i'm gonna get
on the first thing smoking
and that day i was
i waited in the house and i was getting
a haircut and when they told me
that there was a crash it was a mom that
told me and they said they didn't find
all the bodies yet
so they know she was still alive but for
me i was like so it's a wrap
so i hadn't finished my haircut
and i took all of her clothes
out of my house
and everything and i went to go see her
mom
because i just didn't want to be
triggered i was not embarrassed to cry
about losing a lead and i'm still not
but i cried hard in front of people that
thought i was weak i mean i still had to
get myself together and fight because
there were things that were going on
we actually have video of you you're
very at her funeral where you're very
emotional yeah i remember that day
remember that day
i don't revisit it often because it
hurts so it's not like i visualize it
you know so much i see pictures
sometimes
but a lot was going on in that moment
there's a report that
to get on that plane she may have taken
something there's a new report out yeah
i read it
what did you think about that
i didn't really think about it
you know it's like what am i do the
difference does it make at this point
you also said that her death
and then your mother's death shortly
after
yeah it changed you turned you into a
monster
yeah
it made me feel this
because i know what real pain feels like
and i've dealt with it
can't be nothing worse than that
there's a couple things that are a
little worse than that
but or up there
but overall if it ain't that then i'm
not really concerned
and you know
death can't be so bad because you're
going to be with the people you love so
it makes you not fear it
so there's no fear it made me fearless
you know i mean like
i'm not scared anything you talked about
the music coming out now finally
it took a minute and the state wasn't
happy
about this do does the estate want that
music out i don't know
do you think it should have been out a
while ago i'm a fan
of course
and you feel like you're ready for that
rush of aliyah that will come out where
people be playing the music so much more
you know there was a time when she first
passed
a lot of what i did to escape was i went
out every night and what everyone knew
in new york
was when i walked into a club do not
play any earlier but it just took me a
minute it was a process i couldn't even
look at her movies or anything for a
while but now
you know
you never heal but you learn to live
with
you understand what i'm saying so now i
i embrace hearing her music because
there's signs to me it means she's
talking to me it still messes with you
done it no
it doesn't mess with me i mean her it
messes with me that she's not here
but i have no regrets about the way i
you know approach things
because
that's the way you're supposed to
approach things i did what i was
supposed to do i could have never known
anything like that would have happened
yeah in hindsight had i known that then
yes i would have actually broke
boundaries and definitely did things to
make sure she was safe but i could have
never imagined that that type of could
happen
you know what i'm saying yeah
but she was just
she was the coolest
the only person i know as cool as her
are
is rocky and my daughters
but
she was definitely different
and she didn't want to deal with the
[ __ ] like the things that had
happened in the past she told me leave
it alone
i was going to ask you about that
because i figured you were it's back in
the news again
you said that um
after hearing some of this stuff about r
kelly you would need therapy what did
you mean by that
when you hear about things and you can't
do anything about it you have to
internalize
so i have to figure out how to release
it so it doesn't turn into cancer in my
body
that's what i meant
now that we have been
told things that they were indeed
married that he he
feared i knew all that
did y'all ever talk about it
lightly
we talked about it up to the point where
it hurt
and then she said i don't want to talk
about it no more leave it alone
and when she would i kind of didn't want
to know because
her i would have to respect
her wish no matter what and she her wish
was leave it alone let me heal let me
rest let me i'm in love let's just enjoy
this
she had moved past it
yeah
100
and i had helped her
as you hear all this other stuff in the
news with r kelly how do you how does
that make you feel about him
i don't want to say
i think there were all things for all of
us that there were things that kind of
surprised and shocked us then we were
kind of like
i was just shocked at how long he got
away with it
how many people turned and looked the
other way
how many people were still you know
involved with him in any kind of way
knowing all those things
what's your one memory of leah what's
the memory when you think of her what is
the memory that you think of
a moment a conversation a
a trip uh
well we took this one trip
to nevis off season
and no one was there
but the monkeys
i got the pictures
it was just us on an island
for like a couple days
and we really felt like we didn't need
anybody but us it didn't matter about
fame
it didn't matter about money
the wealth was our love
and no one was watching
like i it's almost amazing to me that
i'm the guy that was with aliyah
like i'm almost a fan of myself
like who is that guy who couldn't be
that cool to be able to lead like who
could have actually been with a
me
and that's crazy
so i gotta appreciate that
every year the legend grows and you are
you were part of that legend
what do you think that people
should remember about her what is the
thing what does that mean she's
presented to them great music and swag
the coolest
you know